you got Hufflepuff here uh what most
believed to be hufflepuff's Cup right
here which would eventually become a
horcrux of course here we have
Gryffindor and you can just make out
like you can make out the badger right
there see that and then you've got the H
for Hufflepuff here then here we got
Gryffindor I'm still trying to make out
the exact like where the line is exactly
I mean it's up in here somewhere looks
like the main here but yeah this one has
a little bit more trouble seeing exactly
where the line is and of course you got
the sword the sword of Gryffindor right
here this is the reflection so we're
seeing the outside of it yeah because I
was like what this looks like a p but
now I see it like from the other side
that would be a G right there then we
got Ravenclaw here almost a little bit
of purple let me just the way the
stained glass kind of reflects probably
so you've got the eagle here you've got
the r uh and then what I think is pretty
clearly the diadem which would also go
on to become a horcrux of Voldemort and
then we have Slytherin here and this is
what I think that one people are most
unsure about I mean I feel like just to
go to the theme of the others It's gotta
be slytherin's locket would be the top
of my list to me it visually it looks
more like a resurrection Stone I don't
know from what we know the resurrection
Stone was a pevel family thing but I
don't believe it was a sliver thing the
lock of course was a Slytherin thing so